Bonjour à tous !
Puisque c'est les fêtes de fin d'année, j'ai décidé
de vous parler d'un sujet festif: le champagne.
Alors, je vous avais déjà fait la physico-chimie du pastis
l'été dernier donc ça se complète pas mal.
Aujourd'hui on va se demander
d'où viennent les bulles du champagne,
comment elles se forment et si
ça a vraiment un lien avec sa qualité.
C'est pour la science.
...
♪ [Bouchon qui saute] ♪
La première chose qu'on peut se demander c'est,
les bulles de champagne, c'est des bulles de quoi ?
C'est évidemment un gaz et plus précisément
du gaz carbonique, du CO2.
Oui, c'est le même CO2 dont on avait parlé
la dernière fois et qui réchauffe la planète.
Sauf que, rassurez-vous, dans une bouteille de champagne
il n'y a que quelques grammes de CO2
et donc ce n'est pas en buvant du champagne
qu'on va réchauffer le climat,
enfin, il faudrait vraiment en boire beaucoup.
Evidemment, ce CO2 n'est pas présent initialement dans
le jus de raisin qu'on utilise pour faire le champagne
et il est le résultat d'une étape vraiment spécifique
de la méthode champenoise de vinification
qu'on appelle la seconde fermentation.
En fait, après la première fermentation du vin,
au moment où on s'apprête à mettre
le champagne dans les bouteilles,
on lui ajoute un liquide qu'on appelle la liqueur de tirage
et qui contient, entre autres, du sucre et des levures.
Pendant le vieillissement du vin,
il se produit une réaction chimique lente
au cours de laquelle les levures
vont fermenter le sucre en alcool
tout en produisant au passage du CO2.
Comme cette opération a lieu dans la bouteille fermée,
le CO2 s'accumule dans la bouteille,
sauf que quand on regarde une bouteille
de champagne avant de l'ouvrir,
il n'y a pas de bulles dedans, donc le CO2 il est où ?
En fait il est à deux endroits,
il est en partie sous forme gazeuse
dans l'espace libre qui est situé au niveau du goulot
et il est en partie dissous dans le liquide.
Le CO2 qui est situé sous le goulot est évidemment
celui qui cause la pression dans la bouteille
et qui fait sauter le bouchon au moment où on l'ouvre
et à cet endroit il peut régner
une pression d'environ 6 bars.
Le CO2 qui est dissous dans le liquide, c'est un petit peu
plus difficile de se représenter de quoi il s'agit.
En fait, il faut s'imaginer des molécules de CO2
qui se promèneraient librement dans le liquide
assez isolées les unes des autres
et il faut voir qu'entre le CO2 qui est dissous
et le CO2 qui est sous forme gazeuse,
il existe une relation d'équilibre.
Ça se traduit par le fait que la pression
et la concentration de CO2 sont proportionnelles.
Cette relation de proportionnalité entre la pression
dans le goulot et le CO2 dissous dans le liquide,
on l'appelle la loi de Henry
et en fait elle n'est pas du tout spécifique
du CO2 et du champagne,
elle vaut pour les gaz dissous en général.
Mais dans le cas spécifique du champagne,
la constante de proportionnalité est
à peu près 2 grammes/litre/bar.
Ça veut dire que pour 6 bars de pression dans le goulot,
la concentration de CO2 dissous dans
le champagne est à peu près de 12gr/L.
Maintenant, qu'est-ce qu'il se passe quand
vous ouvrez votre bouteille de champagne ?
Tout le CO2 qui était accumulé dans le goulot
va s'en aller très rapidement
et donc la pression va chuter brutalement.
Du point de vue de la pression totale, on passe de 6 bars
à à peu près 1 bar, la pression atmosphérique,
mais en fait, dans la loi de Henry, ce qui compte c'est
la pression qui est spécifiquement exercée par le CO2
et comme il n'y a presque pas de CO2 dans l'atmosphère,
la pression de CO2 est essentiellement de 0
Vous voyez que du point de vue
de la loi de Henry, si la pression chute à 0,
la concentration de CO2 dissous dans le liquide,
vu qu'elle est proportionnelle, devrait aussi chuter à 0.
Donc ça veut dire que tout ce CO2 dissous dans le champagne
doit s'échapper et se barrer sous forme gazeuse.
Ce passage de forme dissoute à forme gazeuse
est ce qu'on appelle un changement d'état.
C'est un peu comparable, par exemple, à l'ébullition de l'eau
ou alors à la congélation, le changement de l'eau liquide
en glace est aussi un changement d'état.
Il y a un truc important à savoir sur les changements
d'état, c'est qu'ils ne sont pas automatiques,
ce n'est pas parce que les conditions sont réunies
pour qu'un changement d'état se produise
qu'il va se produire tout de suite.
L'exemple le plus connu est
ce qu'on appelle la surfusion de l'eau.
C'est un phénomène assez spectaculaire
qui fait qu'on peut refroidir de l'eau liquide
en dessous de 0°C sans qu'elle congèle tout de suite.
En fait si on la refroidit vraiment très précautionneusement,
elle peut rester liquide, même si on va à -10°C
et c'est seulement s'il y a un choc ou alors une poussière
qui va perturber cette eau liquide,
que la cristallisation en glace peut s'initier.
La surfusion de l'eau, c'est une manip
vraiment sympa que j'aurais aimé vous faire,
mais en fait à chaque fois que j'essaie de la faire,
ça rate, donc peut-être pour une prochaine fois.
En tout cas, pour le CO2 qui est dissous dans le champagne,
il se passe exactement la même chose
que pour l'eau en surfusion,
c'est-à-dire qu'en principe il devrait changer d'état
et donc il devrait se transformer sous forme gazeuse,
mais pour que ça se fasse en pratique,
il faut que quelque chose l'y pousse
il faut un événement déclencheur
et le mieux c'est d'avoir ce qu'on appelle un site de nucléation,
c'est-à-dire un endroit où ce changement va pouvoir s'effectuer.
D'ailleurs, quand on regarde une flûte de champagne,
on voit comme des séries de bulles
qui montent en colonnes, en petits trains,
et ça laisse bien penser qu'à la base
de la colonne, il y a un truc spécial
qui fait que les bulles se créent dans des sites spécifiques.
Une manière simple d'avoir un site de nucléation,
c'est d'avoir une petite poche de gaz
et d'ailleurs pendant un moment, on a pensé
que les aspérités naturelles du verre
pouvaient emprisonner un petit peu d'air
au moment où on faisait le service du champagne
et servir ensuite de site de nucléation.
D'ailleurs, un truc qui marche bien, c'est de s'amuser
à graver l'intérieur d'un verre parce que les gravures
vont pouvoir emprisonner un petit peu d'air
et servir de site de nucléation pour les bulles.
Pour que ça fonctionne bien, il faut graver assez fort
et on a compris depuis que les aspérités
naturelles du verre étaient en fait trop petites
pour servir de site de nucléation
et donc être à l'origine du phénomène.
C'est que l'explication est ailleurs.
Pour trouver la source des bulles
du champagne, Gérard Liger-Belair,
qui dirige, à l'université de Reims une petite
équipe de recherche consacrée au champagne
a dû faire des observations très précises.
Il a placé un verre de champagne
près d'une camera avec un microscope
et il a pu identifier le coupable.
Le coupable ce n'est pas les aspérités du verre,
ce sont des petits bouts de fibres de cellulose,
tels qu'on en trouve un peu partout autour de nous
et notamment dans les verres
et ces petites fibres de cellulose vont servir
de véritables usines à bulles
selon un mécanisme qui est assez amusant.
En fait, une fibre peut emprisonner
une toute petite poche d'air dans sa structure
qui va rester au moment ou on sert le champagne
et quand le CO2 qui est dissous dans le vin
se trouve en contact avec cette petite poche d'air,
il commence à migrer et vient faire grossir la poche
et quand elle a suffisamment grossi,
sous l'effet de la poussée d'Archimède,
elle s'arrache de la fibre et elle monte dans le verre.
Là, le miracle qui se produit, c'est qu'un petit bout de
la bulle reste toujours coincé, prisonnier dans la fibre
et peut resservir pour recommencer le cycle de bullage.
C'est pour ça qu'on voit toujours des colonnes
de bulles qui montent du même endroit,
en fait, certainement qu'à la base de chaque colonne
il y a une petite fibre de cellulose.
Ces fibres de cellulose peuvent provenir
par exemple de nos vêtements
et donc si vous voulez des belles bulles
dans vos verres de champagne,
le meilleur moyen c'est de laver les verres
à la main et de les essuyer avec un chiffon
et comme ça vous aller laisser à la surface du verre
tout un tas de fibres de cellulose
qui vont servir d'usines à bulles une fois
que vous aurez versé votre champagne.
...
Maintenant, on va en venir à la question
qui intéresse plein de monde.
Quel lien y a-t-il entre les bulles de champagne et sa qualité ?
La première chose qu'il faut dire, c'est que les bulles
jouent un rôle essentiel dans la dégustation.
En fait, quand elles remontent dans le verre,
à l'interface entre les bulles et le champagne,
il y a tout un tas de molécules aromatiques
qui viennent se mettre
et ces molécules aromatiques sont dispersées dans
votre bouche au moment où vous buvez le champagne.
Donc les bulles servent en quelque sorte d'exhausteur de goût.
Mais l'affirmation qu'on entend le plus souvent,
c'est que des bulles plus fines
seraient le signe d'un champagne de meilleure qualité.
C'est vrai ça ?
En fait non, pas vraiment.
En fait, la taille des bulles dépend essentiellement
de seulement deux facteurs,
la hauteur du verre et la quantité de CO2 dissous dans le vin.
La hauteur du verre, c'est parce que
quand une bulle remonte le long du verre,
elle grossit, elle se charge de CO2,
donc plus le verre sera haut, plus la bulle sera grosse à la fin,
donc avec le même champagne,
si vous le servez dans une coupe, vous aurez des bulles
plus fines que si vous le servez dans une flûte.
L'autre facteur qui joue c'est le taux de CO2
dissous dans le champagne,
plus il est important, plus les bulles grossiront vite.
Donc un champagne qui est un peu éventé
aura naturellement des bulles plus fines,
mais c'est aussi le cas d'un champagne plus vieux
parce qu'il faut savoir qu'au cours de son vieillissement,
le champagne perd un petit peu de CO2 par le bouchon,
il perd environ 1 gramme/litre tous les deux ans.
Donc un champagne plus vieux
aura naturellement des bulles plus fines.
Vous voyez qu'il n'y a pas de lien fondamental entre
la taille des bulles et la qualité du champagne.
A la limite, la seule chose qu'il peut y avoir
c'est une espèce de corrélation apparente
qui est liée au fait que les champagnes qu'on va boire vieux
et donc qui vont naturellement avoir des bulles plus fines,
c'est en général les champagnes de meilleure qualité.
C'est certainement ça qui est à l'origine de la légende,
mais ce n'est pas une relation de cause à effet.
Pour ceux qui ont vu ma vidéo sur le paradoxe de Simpson,
c'est un bel exemple, l'age du vin
joue le rôle de facteur de confusion.
Dans tous les cas, ne vous prenez pas la tête avec
la taille des bulles et profitez bien de votre dégustation.
Voilà, je vous souhaite de passer
d’excellentes fêtes de fin d'année,
amusez-vous bien à faire de la science
à table ou à l'apéritif.
N'oubliez pas de partager cette vidéo
avec votre famille ou vos amis
et on se retrouve l'année prochaine
pour de nouvelles vidéos.
Merci, à bientôt.